- C'était en mai 2021.
Régine Laurent présentait
65 recommandations et 250 pistes
d'actions pour améliorer
la Direction de la protection
de la jeunesse et giquesgiquesgs
comme celle de la fillette
de Granby survenue en 2019.
RÉGINE LAURENT,  enfants enfants
- Leur charge de travail devrait
être moins lourde afin qu'elles
puissent s'occuper adéquatement
des enfants et des familles.
- La commissaire suggérait
entre autres de mieux
soutenir les professionnels
des jeunes de la DPJ.
Mais cette charge de travail
n'a pas diminué, soutient
le syndicat, même si Québec
a annoncé la création
ROBERT COMEAU, prés. Alliance
du personnel de la santé
- Si vous n'améliorez pas
les conditions, que vous
mettiez 500 ou 1000 postesa
l'enjeu. On n'est pas attractifs
dans les centres j
proches d'eux, qui
sont capables de les orienter,
du temps pour se former,
on n'est pas ça... on gère
des urgences actuellement.ccueii
doivent être mieux soutenues,
mieux fo
et mieux valorisées.ération deés
d'accueil et des ressources
iaires du Québec
s'attendait à l'embauche
d'intervenants capables
s besoins
particuliers des enfants. Sa pre
de constater que l'argent
est allé ailleurs.GENEVIÈVE RIO,
Féd. des familles d'accueil
- Sur le terrain,pas encore ou,s
cas, le budget a été utilisé
pour un type d'intervenants
contrôle qualité qui
ne correspond pas, à notre avis,
par le ministre et encore
moins aux recommandations
de la commission.
- Le virage prévention,
c'est obligatoire.
- Selon la commissaire,
les organismes communautaires
et les Cer
les familles vulnérables
afin de e recours
à la DPJ. Mais les délais
sont encore trop longs,
u de la communauté
haïtienne de Montréal.
RUTH PIERRE-PAUL, dg, Bureaudeïe
- Il faut que, lorsque
la référence est faite,
n'ait pas à attendre
une année, deux années
pour recevoir des services.
Il y a urgence d'agir.
- Elle estime aussi que Québ
des programmes d'accès
au logement pour l
qui quittent la DPJ.
Le ministre délégué à la Santé
et aux Services sou
cours des prochaines semaines,
un bilan a été a été a été a été
réalisé. Son cabinet
souligne que plusieurs
des reco travers
la loi 15, qui vient modifier
ur la protur la protur la protun
de la jeunesse.
Ici Valérie-Micaela Bain,